Khloe Kardashian is setting the record
straight following rumors that she
struck up a relationship with Tristan
Thompson while he was still dating
Jordan Craig the mother of his three
year old son Prince
that's ridiculous on Tuesday the reality
star took to her Instagram story to
issue a lengthy statement insisting that
she was told Tristan was single when
they started their romance never forget
it
Chloe recalls how she first met the 28
year old NBA pro when they were set up
on a blind date by a mutual friend
adding after going on some dates Tristan
told me that he had an ex that was
pregnant obviously I was reluctant about
us continuing to date or start a
relationship Chloe says Tristan told her
the relationship was over long before
they met even showing her correspondence
with Jordan to prove it even his inner
circle confirmed his side of the story
Chloe explains quote his best friends
business associates and even his mother
told me him and his ex were broken up
before we met the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star who shares a
one-year-old daughter with Tristan is
adamant that this is her truth taking
one day at a time
quote if for any reason this is not in
fact the truth I am so completely and
utterly sorry that Tristan and his inner
circle would lie on something like this
I really don't know what to believe
truthfully from the deepest parts of my
soul I am sorry I'm sorry for any pain
that has been created either way
Chloe's message comes after several news
outlets cited court documents reportedly
filed in November 2018 by Tristan's ex
over child support in the reported
documents it's alleged that Chloe was
seeing the Cleveland Cavaliers player
while he was still in a relationship
with the mother of his son it's not
crazy
of course Chloe has had her own issues
with Tristan in April 20 18 just days
before the birth of their daughter true
reports surfaced that Tristan had
cheated on Chloe
big mistake they the two decided to stay
together I'm someone who I do like to
put my relationships as a priority and I
tried to make I really try to make that
work but when Tristan was accused of
cheating on Chlo
again nearly a year later this time with
kylie jenner's best friend jordan woods
Chloe called it quits I'm too grown for
that